Let’s look again at the averaging process
that we introduced a segment or two ago. Here
we have our original image of the Mona Lisa
and here we have the version of the Mona Lisa
where we have applied an averaging over a
21 by 21 pixel input window. What can happen
when we perform the average over a square
window it leads to an artefact in the image
called ringing. It introduces very faint vertical
and horizontal lines and we can see a few
above her lips and above and below her eyes.
This problem arises because the pixels in
the input window are different distances away
from the centre of the window. In particular,
this pixel here is the distance of 2 away
from the centre of the window where this pixel
here is a distance 2√2 away from the centre.
That is a value of almost 3 pixels away from
the centre. And the result is that the average
is unduly influenced by pixel values that
are a long way from the centre. And we say
that this operation is not isotropic; that
means that it has different results in different
directions. It is not symmetrical.
Ideally what we would like to do is to extract
a circular region of pixels; we would like
to take all of the pixels that fall underneath
this circular disk. But the problem with this
is that the disk doesn’t fully cover all
of the pixels; some of the pixels around the
edge—particularly the ones in the corner—are
only partially covered by the disk. So that
involves us taking a fraction of a pixel.
Let’s look at a way we can do this.
And the way we do it is to apply a weighting.
Let’s zoom in on this circular region that
we have created and it’s a circle with a
diameter of 2.5 pixels. And we want to take
all of this pixel because it is fully covered
by the disk. But we only want to take a fraction
of this pixel; we want it to have less significance
or less weight in the average that we are
going to compute.
So what we can do is to compute a set of weights.
For pixels that are fully covered by the disk,
the weight is equal to 1. But if the disk
only partly covers the pixel then the weight
is less than one and we can see that there
are some pixels 98% covered by the disk and
in the corners we can see that some pixels
are only 14% covered by the disk. This matrix
then represents the influence that the different
pixels within the square window should have
on the resulting average. How do we use this
weighting matrix?
What we are going to do is to take all of
the pixels from the input image and here is
an example of a set of pixel values. And we
are going to multiply all of the pixels within
the window by the weighting matrix. And this
is an element wise multiplication, sometimes
called a Hilbert multiplication. So we take
corresponding elements from these two matrices,
multiply them together, put the result into
the corresponding element in the output matrix.
So over here we have the pixel value from
the original image, but we have multiplied
them by the weighting matrix so that the ones
in the corners have got a lower value, less
able to influence the resulting average. Now
we will compute the sum over this product
and that is the product of all of the pixels
in the input window which we denote by W and
all of the values in the weighting matrix.
And I am going to now refer to that weighting
matrix as a kernel.
Kernel is a term that is commonly used in
image processing. And we are going to compute
the sum of the element wise multiplication
of these two small square images and the result
is what we place into the output image. So
our function f(W) is equal to the sum of the
element wise multiplication of the input window
and the kernel.
Consider now that I have an input image where
all of the pixels are uniform and equal to
1. If I applied this kernel to that image,
the result will be that every pixel in the
output image would have a value of 19.6. Input
image, the values are all 1, output image
are all 19.6. And we can get around this by
applying a scale factor, and a scale factor
is determined from the sum of all of the elements
within the kernel; if we divide the kernel
by the sum of all of its elements we have
a normalised kernel and if we apply this to
an image, where all of the input pixels have
got a value of 1, the output image will have
all of its pixels equal to one. This is a
normalised kernel, so typically we try and
compute a kernel that has got a scale factor
of 1.
So the simple averaging that we looked at
right at the beginning of this lecture we
can also think of it as a kernel. In fact,
it is a very simple kernel where all of the
elements in the window are equal to 1. So
here is the example for a 7 by 7 window. The
7 by 7 matrix of ones, we divide it by 49
so that the overall scale factor is equal
to 1. So this is a fairly uniform way of dealing
with spatial operations—they can all be
represented by a kernel matrix. And in the
MATLAB tool box we use a function called iconv.
We parse in the image and in this case the
Mona Lisa image. The second argument is the
kernel matrix in this case it is a 7 by 7
matrix full of ones, divided by 49. The function
ones is a built-in MATLAB function.
Another kernel that is commonly used in image
processing is the Gaussian kernel, named after
the very famous German mathematician Carl-Friedrich
Gauss. You have perhaps encountered the one
dimensional version of this function before;
it is the normal distribution that we see
in statistics. This function has got a simple
and elegant analytic form and if we plot it
in three dimensions it has the appearance
of a gentle hill. If, instead, we represent
this function as an image where brightness
is proportional to height of the function
shown over on the left, we have an image that
looks something like this. It is bright in
the middle and we can see that the intensity
falls off uniformly in all directions. This
is an isotropic function and the weight decreases
as we move away from the centre. In the MATLAB
tool box, we can compute this kernel using
the function kgauss. The first argument is
the standard deviation, the symbol σ on the
left, and the second argument is the half
width of the kernel. In this case, the half
width is 15 so therefore the full width is
2x15 + 1; that is, a kernel that is 31 by
31 pixels.
An important parameter of the kernel is the
standard deviation, the symbol σ, which appears
twice in the analytic expression. It controls
the width of the kernels, so for a σ of 2
we see that there is a very tall, pointy peak;
for a σ of 5 it is much broader; for σ 10
it is broader still. The area under the Gaussian
function is always one. So as it gets wider
it becomes less tall. An important consideration
when we use the Gaussian for image processing
is what size should the kernel be. The kernel
needs to be big enough to hold the bulk of
the Gaussian so, and that clearly is going
to depend on the standard deviation. So a
pretty good rule of thumb is to make the half
width of the kernel equal to three times the
standard deviation.
Let’s create one of these Gaussian kernels;
I am going to put it into a variable called
K. It is the kgauss function and I want it
to have a standard deviation of 5 and I wanted
to be in a window with a half width of 15.
So that will actually be 31 by 31 kernel.
There we go. We have created a 31 by 31 matrix
in the workspace which contains the Gaussian kernel.
Now I can display this as an image.
And there we see it is essentially a disk,
it is bright in the middle, it has got a high
weighting to values in the centre of the window
and lower weighting for pixels that are further
away from the centre of the window.
Now I can create in a new figure. And I can
look at it in a different way; I can look
at it in a three dimensional way by creating
a MATLAB surface plot. And there we see the
Gaussian window, very distinctive shape. Tall
in the middle and with the decreasing values
as we go away from the centre.
Let’s apply this kernel to a standard test image,
so we will load the Mona Lisa image.
I will create a new image called S for smooth and I will correlate it with the kernel.
There we have created the output image. I can display
that and we can see that the image has been
smoothed; we might also say it looks a bit
blurry. Looks like it has lost some of its
resolution. What we’ve done is smooth out
the very fine scale detail and left just the
coarse detail in the image.
And you can see that for the Kσ equals 2,
we have a relatively small kernel size; for
σ equals 5, we have to use a much larger
kernel.